cody ponce was a once a brewer at least
a brewer farmhand
not many uh innings yet this year just
eight so those numbers can change in a
hurry
big right-hander delivers and a chopper
onto third hayes meets it near the back
has it
and throws it on to first for the out
one gone
[Applause]
keeps throwing a lot of strikes that's
for sure and a strikeout finally
this one slept in the center of base hit
so
two aboard for the brewers with two outs
here in the first inning so here's
garcia
overall at 239 leads the team with 15
home runs
at the belt coming back swinging a line
drive headed towards the gap in left
center field it's down
and up against the wall on the hop two
runs are gonna score
yelich touches home narvaez scores it's
a two run double for avi garcia
and just like that the brewers are out
in front again
two-nothing milwaukee and jase peterson
is the hitter
3-1 on the way right down the middle
driven into the right field corner
off the wall garcia will score easily
and peterson a stand-up rbi double and
it's
three to nothing milwaukee
jackie bradley jr goes the other way to
left and it's caught out there by
gamble and the first inning finally
comes to an end
eric lauer on the mound the lefty for
milwaukee yeah real good as last time
matt that was against the rockies he
snapped a personal three-game losing
streak
picked up a win against the rocky six
innings only two hits no run
six punch outs yeah for lauer
this one hit to center field jackie
bradley junior's got it for the first
out
brian hayes bats sounds like he broke
his bat
and grounds out for out number two
this one hit hard to garcia and right in
a
quick one two three inning for eric
lauer
and brewer catcher steps in he had a
single and scored the second run of the
ball game
first pitch from ponce swinging a pop-up
third base side
shallow left field now keep ryan hayes
having trouble it's going to fall a base
head
a run is going to score adamus moves to
third and that
tells you everything you need to know
right now about what's going on with the
pirates
so now avi garcia is going to come up he
authored a two-run double back in the
first
here's the o2 to garcia and this one
into right field base hit
another run for milwaukee as adamus
comes in
and narvaez takes third aggressive base
running
and it's five-nothing milwaukee he's
gonna leave
rafael freitas the head trainer wayne
underwood jr will be summoned earlier
than
he had anticipated pirates have two on
with two out for jared oliva
and a line drive toward right center
field and jared
oliver gonna pick up the rbi get the
bucks on the board it's 4-1
jared oliva with his first major league
ribby
and the one-two shot into right field
for a base hit
hiro makes the turn he's on his way to
third and the brewers are in business
here
to short a nice play by the shortstop
newman and the out recorded at home
plate
that was not easy that was an excellent
play i tell you he's
just been brilliant on defense hasn't he
he's been perfect
has not made an error and now they're
loaded for adamus
chopped toward newman scoops tosses gets
the final out
[Applause]
and a liner rate tahira for the first
out here in the third inning
pop-up first base hero drifting into
foul territory right on the line in foul
territory makes the catch
this one hit a long way center field
jackie bradley jr at the wall
he has got it
to short adamus long throw
here's ben gamel and a drive out to
right but playable for garcia he moves
back and on to the warning track and he
makes the catch
one two on the way and strike three
swinging and lauer gets through a little
bit of traffic here
first pitch grounded right to first base
evans comes up to get it and tags the
back for the out one away
here's the pitch and a swing and a miss
lower down on strikes there are two outs
that one strength three at the knees
with a fastball
this one sound like a little broken back
but it's popped out there to peterson
and they retire a dangerous hitter in
adam frazier
[Music]
adamus chance for two the turn by
peterson
and safe is hayes close play
got down there pretty fast
straight away center jackie bradley
junior's got it for the final out
and this one going the other way it'll
drop in for a base hit
and yell at hustles into third base look
at that aggressive base running that
we've been talking about had a good read
off the bat
jace peterson rbi double today
right through the vacated area where the
shortstop normally is yelich comes in to
score narvaez sprints to third
make it 6-1 milwaukee brewer's got
something going here with two down in
the sixth inning bases loaded
jackie bradley jr here's the 2-2
and this one gets past stallings and
into
score for milwaukee another run is
narbaez
and it's now 7-1
a strikeout for lauer number three on
the day for him as stallings goes down
for out number one here in the sixth
and cold strike three top of the zone
and gamble is gone so a couple of
quick strikeouts here to open up the
sixth inning
adamus to second the relay
not in time close over there at first
craig council is going to make the
change trevor richards
will come in good outing for lauer maybe
just kind of ran out of gas here in the
seventh inning
here's omar narvaez he's four for four
1-0 pitch
swinging ground ball that's going to do
it base said adamus had to avoid it omar
narvaez
a five-hit game the first in brewers
history
for a catcher first in third down for
milwaukee
and first pitch for garcia into right
field base hit
and a run comes home 2-2 to peterson
and it gets through right field base hit
and another run comes home for milwaukee
and it's going to be first and third
again
and it's a fly ball to deep right field
ben gamel clears the deck again with
another cannonball
against his former team
garcia base hit into center field and
milwaukee will play run number 10
on the afternoon as tyrone taylor scores
garcia big night at the plate here
is fifth rbi
here's the 1-2 and there's the strikeout
to end it for
milner and the brewers impressive win
again number 11 in a row